Quantitive research is effectively
research with numbers.
Those numbers could be test grades.
They could be scores on
some attitude inventory.
They could really be any kind
of objective measure of reality.
The really nice thing about quantitive
research is it gives us a toolbox of
analyses we can use with our data to
understand the conclusions of it.
We could, for example, compare the means
of two different groups to see if one
outperformed another on some task.
We could analyze how a group of
students performed after getting
some intervention from us to see if some
measure of their performance improved.
So the nice thing about quantitative
research is it has a suite of
tools we can use to create
easy-to-understand,
easy-to-defend conclusions
about our research.
Now two places we get a lot
of quantitative data for
quantitative research are controlled
experiments and survey results.
But those aren't the only two places.
So here we'll talk about the different
places we can get quantitative data for
this kind of research and
some of the different analyses we
can use to process this research.